era conocida como la princesa del pueblo
por su cercanía con la gente desde su
llegada a la familia real británica en
1981 lady y destacó por querer
desmarcarse de la típica rigidez que
caracteriza a la monarquía en reino
unido- una postura que la llevó a ser
activista en varias luchas y a tomar
posiciones nada convencionales en su
cargo
creo que la imagen de diana ha vivido
mucho tiempo y su legado ha perdurado
ella fue el primer miembro de la familia
real en involucrarse con pacientes con
vih en un momento en el que estaban
siendo rechazados evitados por todo tipo
de gente
y paul además de su acercamiento a
pacientes con vih la princesa fue muy
activa en el desminado de regiones en
conflicto como angola y buscó formas de
ayudar a personas que padecían cáncer o
enfermedades mentales y que sufrían un
alto estigma pero su cercanía trajo
muchas críticas que también se volcaron
sobre su vida personal situaciones que
la pusieron bajo el foco mediático hasta
el punto de llegar al acoso
especialmente tras su divorcio con él
carlos en 1996 algo que incluso fue la
causa de su fallecimiento en 1997 ya que
el accidente automovilístico fue tras
subir de la prensa su muerte fue un
shock para la sociedad británica e
incluso puso contra las cuerdas a isabel
segunda que fue criticada por su papel
aunque era un ser humano especial y
dotado en las buenas y en las malas
nunca perdió su capacidad de sonreír y
reír ni de inspirar a otros con su
calidez y amabilidad shawn johnson
jaimes pero más allá de su final la
figura de diana sigue estando presente
para millones de admiradores gracias a
su legado